[Music]
a crisis is an opportunity riding on a
dangerous wind
[Music]
it's better to be without a book than to
believe a book entirely
a little impatience will spoil great
plans
[Music]
if you bow it all bow low
[Music]
a journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step
a smile will gain you ten more years of
life
a bird does not sing because it has an
answer
it sings because it has a song
a book holds a house of gold
talk does not cook rice
[Music]
a man who cannot tolerate small
misfortunes can never accomplish great
things
[Music]
experience is a comb that nature gives
us when we are bald
[Music]
be not afraid of growing slowly be
afraid of standing still
[Music]
treat everyone as if receiving a guest
[Music]
a fall into a ditch makes one wiser
better a diamond with a flaw than a
perfect pebble
he who asks is a fool for five minutes
he who does not ask remains of who
forever
[Music]
an inch of time is an inch of gold
but you can't buy that inch of time with
an inch of gold
a closed mind is like a closed book just
a block of wood
[Music]
better to light a candle than to curse
the darkness
a needle is not sharp at both ends
[Music]
even a hair will bite when it is
cornered
habits start as cobwebs but grow to
become cables
[Music]
the best time to plant a tree was 20
years ago
the second best time is today
in a book of many words there is bound
to be a mistake
[Music]
govern a family as you would cook a
small fish
gently
[Music]
patience is a bitter plant but its fruit
is sweet
listening well is as powerful as talking
well
and is essential to true conversation
two good talkers are not worth one good
listener
[Music]
a hundred no's are less agonizing than
one insincere yes
he who cheats the earth will be cheated
by the earth
[Music]
it takes a man to swallow an insult
one beam no matter how strong cannot
support an entire house
better the cottage where one is merry
than the palace where one weeps
distant water does not put out a nearby
fire
the more acquaintances you have
the less well you know them
he who thinks too much about every step
he takes will always stay on one leg
all things change and we change with him
if you want to find out about the road
ahead
ask about it from someone coming back
genius can be recognized by its childish
simplicity
there are two kinds of perfect people
those who are dead
and those who have not yet been born
a clear conscience never fears midnight
knocking
learning is a weightless treasure you
can carry easily
[Music]
want a thing long enough and you won't
[Music]
married couples tell each other a
thousand things without speaking a word
small men think they are small
great men never know they are great
do everything at the right time and one
day will seem like three
[Music]
solve one problem and keep a hundred
others away
it is easy to open a store but hard to
keep it open
to be totally at leisure for one day is
to be immortal for one day
fool me once shame on you
fool me twice shame on me
[Music]
teachers open the door
but you have to enter
[Music]
ripe fruit falls by itself
but it doesn't fall into your mouth
if you are patient in a moment of anger
you will escape a hundred days of sorrow
[Music]
before preparing to improve the world
first look around your own home three
times
[Music]
i was angered for i had no shoes
then i met a man who had no feet
[Music]
men trip not on mountains but on mole
hills
[Music]
do you not want others to know what you
have done
better not to have done it
[Music]
a man without a smiling face must not
open a shop
[Music]
it is not the knowing that is difficult
but the doing
[Music]
a wise man makes his own decisions
an ignorant man follows the crowd
[Music]
the people who talk the best are not the
ones who tell the most interesting
stories
give a man a fish and you feed him for a
day
teach a man to fish and you feed him for
a lifetime
[Music]
do not believe that you will reach your
destination without leaving the shore
[Music]
if you want to avoid being cheated
ask for prices at three different shops
[Music]
a clever person turns great troubles
into little ones
and little ones into none at all
the person who is his own master cannot
tolerate another boss
[Music]
guessing is cheap but guessing wrong can
be expensive
[Music]
learning is a treasure that will follow
its owner everywhere
[Music]
a bird can roost but on one branch
a mouse cannot drink more than its fill
from a river
[Music]
never trust a woman who has had sex with
your enemy
a person of high principles is one who
can watch an entire chess game without
making a comment
[Music]
to know another is not to know the
person's face but to know the person's
heart
no matter how tall a mountain is it
cannot block the sun
tenacity and adversity are old foes
[Music]
think about your own faults during the
first half of the night and the faults
of others during the second half
if you want your children to have a
peaceful life
let them suffer a little hunger and a
little cold
[Music]
[Music]
you